we're asked to apply the distributive
property to factor out the greatest
common factor we have 35 plus 50 is
equal to so let me get my scratch pad
out
so we have
35
plus 50
is equal to now what's the greatest
common factor of 35 and 50. so what's
the largest whole number that's
divisible into both of these
well i could write 35 as let's see i
could write that as 5 times 7
and i could write 50 as 5
times 10 and so we see 5 is the greatest
common factor 7 and 10 don't have any
factors in common so i could rewrite
this i could write 35 as equal to 5
5 times 7
and i could rewrite 50 as equal to
another color here i could rewrite 50 as
5 times 10
5 times 10 and of course i'm adding them
so i have plus right over here if i want
i could put parentheses but order of
operations would make me do the
multiplication first anyway
but now i want to factor out that
greatest common factor i want to factor
out
i want to factor out the 5. so we're
really doing right over here is i am
unwinding the distributive property so
if i factor out a 5 this is going to be
equal to
this is going to be equal to let's
factor out the 5 5 times
so you do 35 divided by 5 you're just
left with the 7. you're just left with
the 7 over here
so you're just left with the 7 after
you've factored out the five and over
here you're just left with the ten
so five
are seven
plus
seven
plus ten and we're done 35 plus 50 is
equal to five times
7 plus 10. so let me let me now go and
type that in
so
this is the same thing
as
5
5
times
7
plus 10. and you know you factored out
the greatest common factor because 7 and
10 don't have any factors in common
anymore that they're called relatively
prime they have no factors in common
other than one so we could we could now
check that let's do
let's do a couple more of these
apply the distributive property to
factor out the greatest common factor so
let's see if we can just do this one a
little bit faster so let's see the
largest numbers divisible
in both 75 and 20.
well i don't know let me try five so
if i say five times so 75 divided by
five let's see is going to be
it's going to be 15 is that right yeah
because 5 times 10 is 50 5 times 5 is 25
yes so it's 15 and i got that 15 by
dividing 75 by 5. so 15
plus
and then 20 divided by 5 would be
20 divided by 5 would be 4.
15 plus 4. let's see did i do this right
15 and 4 don't have any factors in
common and if i were to apply the
distributive property here i'd have 5
times 15 is 75
5 times 4
is 20. yeah i'm feeling good about that
and got it right